before those students make it back to
the classroom they have to get there
safely of course
bianca holman breaks down a few traffic
tips to make sure everything
stays smooth in those school zones all
across the las vegas valley
summer break is over for clark county
school district students class is
in session before the first bell rings
and kids take their seats they must
arrive to campus
unharmed at 20 miles an hour 10 percent
of the population
struck by a vehicle will not survive and
that 10 percent
is the very elderly and small children
because they have no body mass to absorb
the crash force
that's why we ask you to slow down
because if you
strike a child they won't live plain and
simple
drivers be cautious and take it easy
especially in residential areas and
school zones
once you see those yellow and red
flashing lights prepare to stop if
you're behind a school bus
this means children will get on or off
the bus
if you're in the opposite direction and
there's a physical barrier
either grass concrete or guard rail you
can proceed
but still remain on high alert so far
this year we've had 38 fatalities for
pedestrians so those are just people who
are out you know walking riding their
bikes
so we just really need to remind
everybody to please slow down pay
attention and
to the pedestrians out there also we
always like to stress
use the crosswalks they're here for a
reason the red cross recommends students
arrive to the bus stop a little early
and stay away from the curb students
should pay attention to traffic signals
and stay inside the crosswalk
if your child rides their bike to school
be sure they always wear their helmet
and ride
on the right in the same direction of
traffic
these tips can ensure no young life is
taken too soon
bianca holman 8 news now and the red
cross encourages
families to create an emergency plan so
everyone knows who to contact
and where to go if something happens
while children are at school and parents
are at work